[Musique]
allez lutte avec tout ce soir c'est le
premier invité d'autres histoires en
passe d être gérable
[Applaudissements]
oh
j'ai pas pour moi
[Applaudissements]
gérard gérard la dominer le tabouret
sera plus gérable
oui je sais pas comment je suis content
de te voir je t'aime tellement mais
vraiment je suis comme un fou un jour tu
m'avais invité chez toi ben oui c'est un
de mes plus beaux souvenirs de toute ma
vie
non j'étais l'un se dire c'est toi bah
voilà bon alors et moi je suis très
heureux de voir nommé toi tu es aussi
particulier à bordeaux et c'est pas du
tout de la flagornerie pas ce que c'est
c'est pas facile de le faire ce que tu
fais passer à une énergie krumm qui est
que ça mais j'ai connu merci alors oui
j'ai l'énergie de la bêta d'une grande
gentillesse en même temps parce que
c'est vrai tu déconnes tu te fout pas de
la gueule des gens de temps en temps on
a envie parce que j'aimerais qu'il ya
pas apprendre à s en foutent de la
gueule des fous un peu
est ce que tu as déjà fait des émissions
qui était et eroglu à faire alors tu
disais je nous trouve ermewa contival
secte et comptables non je les fais pas
tu ne fais pas tu fais plus trop de télé
mais je fais plus rien moi t'as pas
besoin
même les films ce que tu as encore des
rêves dans le cinéma des mecs avec qui
tu as pas tourné avec ita non mais non
on voit tout mais tant pis s'il est mal
existe de moins en moins ce qui est bien
céder les plateformes jeu non j'ai un
rêve et une chose que je vais faire je
pense c'est de l'animation c'est un peu
comme la bande dessinée des 500 dans les
pattes de la télé parce que si tu
cherches un producteur je tournais non
non pas dans des mazots tdb l'annulation
des films d'animation louis ouais c'est
qu'il attend et qui tu as préféré
tourner j'ai beau qu'on a plein coeur
oui dès qu'ils deviendront bien commun
jésus mots clés ou richard que j'ai de
beaux canine et les fugitifs et oui mes
romans il y avait des acteurs ans a
comme le gaba quand même de long était
un peu un peu un peu un peu aller bien
prendre un bain de foule
là je me suis bien amusé avec ton père
avec son grand père avec
et quand on perd aussi il était
totalement investi dans son rôle avec
l'aviron de la fée marché à bord il
était tellement content la gt il n'ya
pas il ya trois jours dans un poste de
police les noms avaient su y faire peur
parce que je sais que c'est pas ça tu
sais quoi
c'est quoi l'histoire russe servait en
train de manger un bon couscous moulin
bleu du maine
je sais toujours jeter mon petit saïd
cedac là ça me travaille et là je fais
je fais comme tout dans chaque fois je
vais là-bas ouais j'étais avec la dalle
à l'homme script de andré téchiné et à
bien le papa de la top c'est bien le
père de copia puis je fais mon demi tour
messieurs en la ligne blanche a créé la
voiture et rouge jeudi c'est pas vrai
alors là ils reconnaissent les dix poids
dans les meubles annoncé sur le casque
imai
il faut souffler mais vous avez vu ce
que vous avez fait si oui je fais
toujours aimé il ya le feu jim il n'y
avait personne ne veut pas buzzé à
passer devant une bagnole qui va
m'écraser j'ai pas la souplesse d'avant
donc alors je dis ben faites moi souffle
et à ma grande surprise j'avais 0,29
ouais et la c-zéro 25 maintenant oui
mais ça ne savais pas
avec des calculs et ça passe 0,29 c'est
une salade très bien et gray sue fait
dans la même teneur est dangereux pour
la santé bien sûr et donc ouais donc ils
te disent oui ils disent quoi ben on va
j'ai dit donnez moi un autre estime être
un éthylotest l'éthylotest
alors on va dans le lot il y avait un
jeune tunisien très sympathique 2d des
flics impeccable gentil il y avait deux
russes c est grave a dit pas tout ce qui
est dit et là il y avait deux russes et
opal j'ai dit oui
ce 10 mai donc on parle comme ça j oui
j'aime beaucoup là aussi je mets tous à
son commissariat tout ça au commissariat
une soirée au commissariat on est
inquiet mais un peu comme gainsbourg
faisait la suède 2-3 que ses saillies
ensemble frais et donc ça est donc après
je souffle et là je tombe 0,27 à bout
j'en retiens je reste 10 minutes de plus
celui-là mais c'est ça oui bon mais en
fait beau ils m'ont dit tu peux pas
repartir on est obligé s'il n'y a pas de
problème est qu'on le garde de scooter
sur le trottoir janvier à quelqu'un de
chercher voilà un ami qui est aussi un
ami un ami commun c'est yann moix
j'aimerais qu'on teste l'amitié de yann
moix à ton égard
oui donc on va appeler yann moix on va
essayer de le piéger tuvalu dire que tu
es en galère parce que tu t'es fait
choper par ton voisin parce que tu a
défoncé sa voiture avec son scooter ou
bien encore tu t'es fait choper avec
auto scooters donc on est au
commissariat je jouerai une fois de plus
le commissaire divisionnaire blanchard
tu vas voir gérard je suis un acteur
hors pair
là t'as joué avec les plus grands là ça
va te faire tout drôle
alors on sait très bien allez c'est
parti on appelle yann moix podium
on est en direct bien sûr dès cette
année c'est fou même le téléphone milo
allô allô oui oui mais yann oui bonjour
à gérard convaincu ben ça va et war elle
est appelée justement jal est appelé ce
matin là bas j'étais encore là se bat à
non mais je vais partir bientôt tuer ou
à l'abattoir chercher chez nous vers la
chez ma grand mère un bond de demain tu
rentres de bannu vers ho [ __ ] on
sépare le de verre 2,9 r29 vertu rands 2
nevers d'accord
et toi tu vas baisse à baham a su avec
cyril c'était comme à 0 n'ont rien tu
veux mais parce que moi je suis à l'as
tu sais que les flics m'ont chopé il ya
vendredi alors que j'avais 0,27
d'anatole amer 29 après vingt-sept et
après je suis allé au passé de 27 je
pensais qu'on était toujours à 0,50 et
où la météo la bine lachy deux rôles
commissariat j'ai envie de défoncer
[Applaudissements]
yahoo
battus la voilà est-ce que tu peux dire
à ce qu'on doit être faire un baiser
raté la blague
ouais c'est pas mal quand même par dieu
merci
[Applaudissements]